das ist ein nagelneuer fahrradweg
kirchdorf an der amper im landkreis
freising von kirchdorf richtung
burghausen durch das an partei die
jubeljahre die gehören dazu sie sind
planungsfehler verschlammt innen
landratsamt selbst mountainbiker
wolfgang lacher weiß nicht so recht was
er dazu sagen soll
ob das wirklich ein radweg wird wann das
soweit ist ganz einfach und die straße
dritte leben und die radfahrer müssen
jeden profi aus fahren macht spaß ist
eher was für inline skate oder soja
hierfür ganz grobe morgen bei geblieben
parcours auf und ab geht's für genau 500
meter
dann ja dann ist der parcours sowieso
schon wieder zu ende
[Applaus]
also auf zur erlebnistour nach kirchdorf
inn landkreis freising ist sehr viel
unterwegs oder haben schon mal so ein
ihren weg schon mal ein genialer coup
oder doch einfach nur versemmelt darüber
spreche ich jetzt mit andreas schmitz
das mitglied des gemeinderates hallo
herr schmidt ja jetzt ist dieser radweg
in ganz deutschland bekannt war dass er
geplant
das gilt für platin gibt dann war es so
nicht ja das ist absicht der
planungsfehler vom landratsamt freising
gewiss gewesen und man hat es einfach
kurzfristig versucht den fehler zu
korrigieren und jetzt schaut es so aus
wir aussieht zumindest macht das ja das
fahrradfahren ein bisschen spannender
bleibt der weg jetzt auch so laut
landratsamt freising wird das so bleiben
wir sind natürlich dran hier nun
vielleicht korrekturen zu durchzuführen
oder dass das landratsamt uns hier noch
mal eine korrektur erlaubt es ist so
planungsfehler wurde eingestanden das
heißt wir hätten eigentlich
entscheidungs vorschläge bekommen dass
er vielleicht den ersten und den letzten
hügel entfernt oder den fahrradweg zu
einem wirtschaftsweg ab senkt damit die
lücke auch entfernt werden können
wir sprechen von einem planungsfehler
wie genau kam es denn zu den hügeln und
was verbirgt sich unter den hügeln wird
er irgendetwas wichtiges geschützt oder
ein gab es da einfach eine miss
kommunikation wie können wir uns das
vorstellen
ich will natürlich vermeiden dass jetzt
die leute zum graben anfangen
also das ist natürlich so dass die feld
einfahrten die felder die östlich vor
dem radweg sind die landwirtschaftliche
fahrzeuge einfahren können und der
radweg war zuerst eben pleite planiert
und dann hat man festgestellt dass die
feld einfahrten vergessen würden
dann haben wir kurzfristig die
feinplanung geändert und hier fast
asphaltiert und dann haben wir auch zum
ersten mal dieses ergebnis gesehen
nun hat das ganze jahr 3,3 millionen
euro gekostet wurden diese steuergelder
gut eingesetzt
also grundsätzlich das ist ja nicht das
rad der fahrradweg das kleine stück was
3,3 millionen gekostet hat sondern das
ist die ganze straßensanierung inklusive
brückensanierung über die handball
da ist ja wieder kleine teil der
fahrradweg grundsätzlich sind wir
unglaublich froh dass wir diesen weg
jetzt bekommen haben dass die kinder
zukünftig sicher von kirchdorf in die
anderen ortsteile wie is not in
burghausen oder wippen hause kommen und
wieder zurück und sofern es für uns das
geld unglaublich sinnvoll investiert
worden und wir freuen uns dass man in
zukunft den radweg nutzen dürfen auch
wenn er ein paar punkte mehr oder
weniger als letzte frage an sie sind sie
denn die buckelpiste schon entlang
geradelt und wie war es war das lustig
oder hat es sie genervt natürlich haben
wir es gleich ausprobiert auch mit der
familie zusammen
ich glaube das ist eher amüsant die
stören gerade buckel und vielleicht hat
ja jeder lächeln darauf in zukunft in
kirchdorf ankommt